welcome to this video playing DD one of
the most frequent opponents and how many
games I got against them are 15 games
with a 70-percent score we transpose to
the French tirage i'm going to play with
this app for set up a setup that i
always liked from wide in a way but it
is a very it is a dangerous setup for
both sides ok he's so quickly taking
some some space here on there on the
Kings side that's a rather conservative
way to play it now maybe queen bee
six-year I cannot play 22 of course HM
Queen d2 Bishop before so rather
embarrassing rook be one Queen a five
losses the pawn
okay that's not ideal twill be three but
I don't think it's really terrible we
are asking me to wear this is not in any
way fatal okay so sure p IM g 7i i get
the Knight to c3 anyway this makes lots
of sense not to be five possibly and I
still enjoyed the Sun rather typical
space advantage of the French boy
against the French black cod liam is not
in any big trouble or anything but white
is ok as well Joe 96-95 this may be
possible okay again an IP 5 is an idea
okay well no need to rush this I can
also get this serve in with G form the
space gainer again now I need to be
conscious he might come up with Knight
a5 and taking the beep on like be 695
taking this okay i can i can play G for
anyway
gaining more space yeah I cannot really
conveniently take years he can do
capture with the rook it's not a good
structure I don't want to worsen my
structure here interesting okay maybe
and now we can play 95 okay I bishop p1
let's not another problem okay my idea
is to play h4 h5 film cameras I must do
that not another big choice p 3 was
hanging yeah i was thinking age four and
maybe h5 quickly
ok
takes rook takes i have this a trifle
195 and age five yeah it's not not easy
to play this position for both sides hmm
i can also play my g5 and that's h6 okay
i need to take first yeah i was also
thinking about 92 to g3 is this possible
that he may be does he have any serious
counterplay they don't see it at the
moment so my g3 and h5 coming the others
those nights on the queenside they look
active but they don't contribute in any
way to the Kings defense yeah now this
is an interesting idea maybe getting the
Bishop to d3 ok this i need to do anyway
and now Bishop t3m might be an idea
giving up the exchange um huh that's a
very serious um um exchange sacrifice
idea
take it to that slop term that's a very
very strong bishop on f5 if i take it
mmm I can play night e 1 but this Bishop
be one funny enough
I can also just ignore that and play age
five immediately
okay if I take a five now okay we'll
just take with the bishop okay i see ya
very good defense but this song exchange
sec I don't know maybe I should have
taken it but black has a very very good
compensation for the exchange song now
i'm still active at least okay maybe
Here I am if he takes it opens up if I
for the night ok ty morning my chief
maybe I don't really see a big counter
play they don't have much time maybe I'm
also threatening night takes h7 there's
a maid here ok I'm going to take it
Bishop takes an IDF seven checkmate Oh
checkmate once in a while it's good to
have a little trick in the position
quite quite surprising they are very
tough defense that he that he put up
here yeah around here I oops miracle
here in a way yes sir but yeah I don't
think I was worse he already i mean i
have enough initiative on the Kings side
that was very interesting defense with
the
the bishop coming here yeah I don't know
maybe I should take it but no the
computer is giving age 5 as the best
movement it was to take on f5 mmm that
surprises me I was thinking that this
should be very ok for black I'll just
take this ah there's this kind of stuff
I see now why just breaking through here
this is probably very good for what yeah
I didn't I didn't see that in the game I
thought okay that's just continue here
and I have some some active pieces of
course here the idea was if he takes
that I get this this a 5 square for the
night I didn't calculate this really
just hoping that it is okay something
like this is possible Emma okay not
quite sure maybe this is equal I think I
have some compensation so I'm not upon
down for nothing but tricky to play yeah
this yeah this was really based based on
this trick but it seems that it was
really a bad mood when the computer
points out this one ok this is strong
yeah threatening night takes b3 end well
if i take i'm probably a very bad shape
hmm yeah this means them that the
capture is a mistake compounds to play
move like a luigi rocca g3 hmm very
tough to play the idea is that it wants
to cover be three from the side very
tough player I was lucky that he is
stumbled into this this made really ok
thanks for watching